before we go any further I just wanted
to let you all know that in order to
adhere to the Embargo for this game I
had to edit out all cutscenes and
cinematics so sorry if there are some
weird cuts and the video isn't exactly
an hour long because I didn't account
for how many of those I would have to
edit out so yeah no cinematics allowed
until the game actually releases
tomorrow hello everyone I'm Alana ochar
alanazar and welcome to my gaming
channel where today I am very very
excited to be checking out wo long
Fallen Dynasty thank you to koi tecma
and Xbox for sending me a code I played
the demo for this game and adored it
even though I felt like I was terrible
at it um it's a really interesting mix
between Neo and Sakura I felt like and I
love Sakura so I think I had a little
bit of trouble with the demo adjusting
to how recently I'd actually played
Sakura like jumping between two is kind
of hard which is to this game's credit
um so we're jumping into the first hour
now and the way I do these is a bit is
basically like a uh what are we trying
to do faintly visible basically like a
live review kind of I just
share my thoughts and by the end decide
if I want to play more of it or not kind
of a play all pass where you guys get to
see the gameplay in real time so
uh let's do frame rate based on the
speed of this game yes
I'm hyped dude
this is one of my most anticipated games
of the year let's go
I'm currently not able to do anything
that's odd okay
we appear to be stuck
uh
okay now strange it must have been like
an Xbox issue there I think maybe okay
I'm gonna type one
appearance template
[Music]
I think I like the starting guy well
maybe this one let's do this one well
that one
everybody's hot
I'm gonna go with this one for now
It's gotta be the base one okay
stance
what is that changing
oh literally just how these arms and
legs I see okay
to 10 is good
custom colors damn that's that's pretty
extensive that's cool face skin type huh
oh that's age
I'm gonna go like here
nice
yep
okay that's the bass face
full head depth dude I love a good
character creator let me tell you
snazzy's fine cheekbone height
she's going with
hella cheekbony
cheekbone depth
Chic bulge oh that's the bottom
position oh my gosh this is just cheeks
damn
I just try to make everybody look very
Elvish
what would your depth inside your chin
oh okay yeah
chin height
yep chin depth
aside this is this is a very good
character creator I'm a big fan
definition oh my gosh
chin sharpness we probably went pretty
sharp right I feel like that's good
under jaw depth oh my God
oh it's like an overbite wow how cool
I'll go back to zero on that one
all right
Central chin height
not sure what that's changing so I'll
leave it at zero
I think the chain is good
compare to previous
oh it's for each one that's cool
um okay additional features
aging
yeah I like that that's good
magic sides yeah eyebrow type okay
uh It's gotta be this one surely
that's good too though I like that
you should look really surprised all the
time
zero that seems fine too
I guess pacing seems good and eyebrow
height
a little bit Mata
mid brow height
it's good
this is really neat very big fan of a
good character creator I'm sorry I'll
try not to suspend the whole game yeah I
just love them and I know other people
like to see them too so
I think uh
cool eyes
I type
I feel like
that one's pretty good to be honest
I don't know that any of this really
needs to change
teardruff bulge
oh my gosh
wow
uh Iris
damn that's really cool
wow I don't know if I've ever seen that
before
um I usually go with a yellow or purple
beautiful
I wonder what the custom colors look
like edit
oh yeah just like very
very customizable huh
oh they're like gray white looks really
cool
I'm gonna do
like here I think
a little more greeny
oh it's more green than I thought maybe
I should just stick to this one now
that's too yellow okay I'm sorry
Bella
cool okay
nose huh
step this from the other side yeah
loves a pointy nose
width find how it was I think
angle line
bone height
gotta be kind of pointed
she's going for Elvis root
what the hell is that
I didn't even notice oh it's that's like
the the bridge no bridge is the middle
part
it is cool that it highlights them
Slim
no that's really cool damn this big fan
of this
nose is good mouth
this one
let me get a little bit higher
mouth Corner angle
super serious
mouth Corner position
oh how far out it goes it's fine I have
the lip thickness
oh lip thickness
up a lip Edge thickness what
I see okay
mouth Corner fat whip
pull through width
oh that's like the changes to Cupid's
bow
I like the Expressions too dude oh he's
so hot okay what you got do you have
anything Elfie for me
there we go
of that
you guys can probably stay I don't know
that I need to change those face
decoration
type I love a skull
I'm gonna move it
down
and over this way and I'd like to rotate
it
there you go hell yeah
luster it's gonna be shinier
that's sick close me up
damn these are all really cool
I like this one I don't know what it
means but I like it
let's do that
is a bit higher
make it more opaque
and like a little bit red
don't know what it is
but I'm a fan
okay that's all we need for face to her
ear accessories
now you could
oh no that's just that one thing I'm
sorry everybody
I try to make sure I play through them
organically even though I'm still
judging it right like
you don't wanna
cheat my way through oh beautiful bro I
wish you know that's the kind of hair
I'm trying to have in my life
we do not be looking like that
so I like this one a lot that's very
cool
otherwise it's got to be this one
now we're gonna do this one
you can even change the just the bangs
part
oh
that's so cool
damn
um
I like that
flip horizontally
top rear hat holy [__] dude
that's the one I think I had
I'm gonna do that one well that one
um
no I like your ponytail dude bottom rear
hair just being real long
it's nice
holy hell it's so cool
that's got to be like white
oh with a dark gray
go with a lighter gray
a highlight color
I let it have tip color
that's got to just be straight white
right
maybe like here
this has to be slightly darker
here
uh tip color base color yeah that seems
fine oh it just I just ended up the same
color didn't I hang on
this one's just a little bit too light
how do I edit it
um
you have to pick another
foreign
six okay
yeah that's cool
hair tips
dude
curliness
this is an amazing character creator
what the hell
on the back
needs to be long
the sides can't tell
do you think I want maybe these ones to
be
shorter
oh my God I love him
oh my God this is so sick okay
this one but make it black
facial head degradation
oh great gradation gray hat nice
okay that looks bad unfortunately
because the blotches and I like it
that's a bummer
mustache type
this is so cool makeup you probably
don't need any we can maybe give you
some eyeliner
I can't really tell the difference that
seems fine
blush you want some blush dude
now you're good
thanks me
look at that too okay body height and
tall
head size
I don't know how to scale whatever I'm
not really sure
shoulder width
body size combined adjustment
I'm gonna go this way
muscle definition extreme
maybe that's slightly too far
chest size nice
what does that look like in the other
character models
body accessory oh that's just more
tattoos
um
whoa
that's awesome
we're gonna do that one because you look
like a Mage and then I kind of want to
make it blue
but like a really light blue
like that
hell yeah I make it a little bit oh I
didn't change anything
you can look a little bit more opaque
needs to stand out
love that
voice
I think I like one good with it
a little bit deeper
go with it
yes he looks incredible 20 minutes sorry
everybody
okay
so this game does not look good I will
say that pretty early on
um
I love the Character Creator obviously
this is not
graphically blowing my socks off though
for reference I did choose FPS mode
because I felt like it would be
important for the speed of this combat
um
and I am playing on a series s just
because that's the one I used to record
but not not a huge fan of this
graphically let's swap over and see if
there's a big difference
let's see
yeah
I think I want the FPS back but it's
just it's not a great looking game that
is the thing that happens
I don't hate a game for not being
stunning graphically but it is obviously
a very immediate thing
to note not
not looking
particularly modern unfortunately
um
am I supposed to fight this guy okay
normal attack Spirit attack normal
attacks are fast and can easily increase
your spirit Superior Texas slow but deal
more Spirit damage which can reduce the
enemy's Spirit gauge
furthermore when you have positive
spirit you can consume the circle Spirit
to increase damage I like that there's a
video showing me everything so sorry
the jump feels cool Loot on RT is a
little strange I'm Gonna Keep exploring
this way though
but I don't think you'll be able to pass
through this way thanks I see that I've
yeah yeah I know I was just grabbing
stuff all right
I'm not sure how to guard oh lb there
you go okay
welcome in the ones that's cool
that's super neat
with the spirit damage just because it
was sort of wider so lb's God
yeah I haven't played the demos since it
came out obviously so it's been a minute
um okay deflect b l s right before
receiving an enemy attack
using B will allow you to redirect your
enemies attack time is I remember this
timing this action to meet the enemy
attack not only allows you to redirect
the attack it also lowers the enemy's
Spirit cage okay
so BB is Dodge
that work yeah
I stepped on it twice I should have done
it twice so let's try and
cool okay that feels really awesome
very big fan of that system I'm sure
that can get super overwhelming really
fast but that feels it feels great it's
very intuitive
oh that was interesting
wait what oh because I have myself well
he did just throw me under the fire okay
crushing defeat
so you can hold block and Dodge and I
guess I keep being compelled to double
hit Dodge which you should not do
um
but that's cool also how do I heal
oh
that's a pretty flaw checkpoint but
that's all right
I like the chance to be able to do that
particular thing again in any case
they look on you
nice
I missed this last time
oh loot
I wonder if I can take a look at what
things are
inventory
sometimes or grants 100 genuine key
unknown how comes to genuine key form
okay
obviously got no equipment
nameless Warrior gob
Dragon cure pot restores HP when used
can I
I don't want to use it
I want to assign it but I'm worried that
if I press a I'll use it so let's just
not
we'll just wait a minute
yeah the Dodge system feels really good
I like it a lot
very big fan super satisfying
um obviously I'm rushing through this
right now where it's very much
tutorialized
but I can
see this quickly becoming something that
you like can't mess around with you
really got to be meticulous and point
for pressing one you know
if we lower that it might serve as a
platform
I want to skip out what's over here that
first you understand
sorry bro
it's a meaning an enemy with high morale
is certain to end badly for you
okay do they have high morale they do
have really unreal committed wine
um
did I touch him I'm not sure
okay Eastside
so is auto mapped to that which is great
I don't want to get in the fire
get out of there
so good that the Y move adds a bunch of
range to you as well
oh now my morale is too okay I see
so that like encourages you to get a
streak up I suppose should I be going
this way or should I have gone the other
way I regret that I didn't go back there
or maybe it's a metroidvania type where
it's like just leading me
the two parts you know
very Heimer also
an enemy will wind up to perform a
critical blow which cannot be blocked
with God taking damage from a critical
Global although your morale rank buy one
if you redirect an enemy's critical blow
the power of the deflect increases and
you significantly break okay so
strongly encouraged to redirect failed
cool
so the combat feels really impactful and
I think a big part of that is
on point sound design
but also the speed
which is why I think I stick with the
FPS
possible
this
increases my defense and physical
resistance and spirit defense what is it
decreasing
the weight category of a sama the weight
of the sama
affects how much damage yet
measure resistance to Elemental damage I
see so different kinds of Elemental
damage
I feel like I'm okay with that
special effect details stealth
toxin attack power melee attack damage
Wizardry spell damage interesting
we're gonna do this for now for the
defense points
but that's an interesting system like I
wonder how
um
how in depth that'll get like if I end
up wanting to play a mage which is
likely because I like doing that
documents character directory
um
if there's gonna be like you know things
that are much better suited to
magic uses or whatever after resting at
a Battle Flag your HP and uses Dragon to
kill but we were stored okay so I
probably have three of them all the time
you can also access it right okay very
very secure
in a way that I love
I remember this too from the demo
raising the battle Flags
your morale rank drops and you are
killed but it will not go below the
fortitude rank okay
surely I can't do that yet oh gosh
okay
I can't get something so would virtue
affects HP and the small sorry and the
amount of spirit lost when attacked
affects the amount of spirit gained when
attacking and the amount of spirit
achievement martial arts effects the
equipment weight limit oh interesting
effects duration that a high level of
spirit can be maintained for water is
affects how easily enemies can detect
you damn so we're just gonna go with
this one for now because I don't oh can
I
maybe I can't
um because I don't
okay it's up I don't really know
just yet what I'm gonna want to favor
which like I wonder if there's a way of
respect at some point too without a
preparation oh I forgot about this stuff
as well that's right I'm Divine beasts
this game's really cool I think I'm
gonna love it
um again I do think it's pretty ugly
um
and I'm not a fan of the voice cast uh
it's visual strike from Ria or above
enemies okay I still think it could be
fun I did a lot of self and sucker and
this stuff like like this oh [__]
um God that feels awesome
I completely forgot what I'm saying
sorry
shred carefully
really
I feel like we're okay
is that where you came from must be
right yeah okay
City
dude what's going on over there
um so far obviously also extremely
linear
but I don't necessarily feel like that
is a problem
um this is still just a tutorial
I expect it to expand
significantly
of course
yeah thanks blindfolded boy
out of such unworldly things found their
way here oh and that's a big boy
probably gonna die here
I died while healing
it'll happen I messed that up though
it's my fault
I will take the L
L taken
oh and I was beginning to God yeah
um okay Revenge slash re-challenge you
will lose your morale points and half of
your genuine key when you are killed by
an enemy so that really encourages you
to level up
with all the key you have you can
reganiel us genuine key and morale
points by defeating the same enemy I
like that a lot
um that could end up being extremely
frustrating
all very compelling
be very interested to see what reviews
say uh when this video goes up if that
ends up being really really frustrating
because the game could theoretically
just get hotter and hotter and hotter
if you lose your morale points certain
enemies of time are all will be really
hard to fight though I guess
in theory you could run back through an
area to kill people with low and morale
to get your morale back up
yeah you could grind your way through it
but that's instead of just dropping
souls or whatever
the concept here is that you have to
actually fight whoever killed you um
I definitely think that's interesting
could go either way
I'm excited by it right now
is there anything in these I should have
checked on
16 dude maybe I just shouldn't even
fight this thing but it killed me I'll
try one more time I don't like my
chances of being able to kill this right
now though
don't mind me sir
just welcome past
oh that's so cool dude
that again probably deserved
um
the way that the Dodge feels with an
enemy that's moving that fast is awesome
it feels very very very fun
no no I'm good I'm good give me one more
shot man
I'm learning not winning you know
but I will have just lost all of that
key because he killed me twice I guess
it was fine I didn't have very much
anyway obviously but
worth noting
he did get me
I'm stuck that's that's not great that's
not great
um
so that's also definitely going to be a
problem here is I feel like there's like
maybe potentially some quality issues
we'll see how that goes and that I just
couldn't Dodge them despite the fact
that I was pressing the button I was
stuck between
two things
um
and again it's hard to say because this
area is just so linear oh I forgot about
you sorry dude
anyway ladies
I'm probably not supposed to fight it
you know it is level 16. I'm gonna try
it one more time because I really want
to fight it
I just kind of I think I can only get
hit like once or maybe twice at most you
know
foreign
but I didn't
you know I think we're gonna skip it for
now
but I do think it's doable you just
can't get hit
um but I won't subject all of you that I
might might like start a second save
just to go through and do it
I'm also just not loving these
environments
oh
can I get over there oh I suppose I can
um just a part of fire blocking me
it doesn't look great
well hello there
oh I didn't even see y'all here
let's do you first huh
very good so dramatic
you try to run away from me oh he's
finding my blindfolded friend
back on you I can't see you right now
level five huh
this game rules the combat rather rules
I'm a really big fan
oh I did that a little bit this time
yeah the combat is really fun
um
the way that mechanic works is just
really satisfying so having not claimed
this one
up in this Village
there are so many of us
yeah yeah I don't need your sub story
something something family something
something
oh what do they like
like some sort of zombies I didn't even
realize
some nice enemy variety already
no I'm level six I wanna all right I
need to understand how that mechanic
Works a little bit but
I want to go back to my level 16 boy
I know they're not actually levels but
you can't
hey lads
the speed the the
comment almost feels like sort of
platinum-y in a way that I really really
love like a little bit you know
Bayonetta e-ish e
I don't know how to get it though
a call that is but it's what came to
mind
martial arts
that's right
unleash powerful martial arts attack
that can pierce the enemies God by
consuming Spirit you cannot perform
martial arts when you have Spirit gauge
decreases to the lower limit the type of
martial odds will differ depending on
the weapon you use only rare weapons
have two kinds of martial arts okay
so it's it's for God right
all right I'm gonna do it right because
I missed Maybe
hang on hang on I'm trying to do the
tutorial my man
[Music]
hey thanks pal I really appreciate that
this looks breakable
I guess not okay
which way there's so many pods
is this where I came from yes okay good
all right take it back there's only one
pop
I'm messing myself up real bad it's
because it's just like tilt forward on
LS which is just sort of awkward
oh
you didn't need to go that hard on him
okay so yeah the martial arts are just
always gonna like break their guard
which is awesome good to know
I see you
and I wonder if these things are going
to be this common
outside of the tutorial Zone it's it's
interesting there's a lot of like things
here that
are pretty unique
um
and I just I wonder if they're gonna pay
off it's really hard to say well I can't
stop past you surely
so [__] cool so cool Dear God
it feels so good
a well-earned victory
I hope that everyone who escaped the
brutalities
yeah a lot a lot to be left as I had
graphically unfortunately
it is what it is it also I just feel
like the animation
like this run animation sort of
all feels a little bit dated again this
is not stuff that I care about a ton but
if we're doing this like
live review play or pass thing that I'm
doing
um
it's worth noting for people who do care
so I think that I want to upgrade the
this one
let's do it
just because I feel like everyone's
noticing me a little bit faster than I
would like
Wizardry spells my my
okay close down a bolt of lightning on a
locked on target or an appointment in
front of you hell yes dude
okay I have to start at the base right
yeah so Unstoppable Force increases
automatic recovery during low Sprint and
decreases automatic
I would like to learn this one
for now
um I don't think I can learn anything
else right like how do I get to the
others at the top I don't think I can
because I haven't lied any of them I
don't imagine I can get that too right
no so then we're gonna set Wizardry
spells
amazing is that is that why
because if yes
it's the same system as the first Fable
and as kingdoms of Amala which is my
favorite magic system that it's RT and
any of the face buttons
I love it
I think I'm gonna love this game
so far I
I think it's like obviously we've got
another 15 minutes or so
um before I'm supposed to wrap up this
play out pass but
it has a lot of systems I love I think
that maybe it could suffer from some
quality issues
just based on my initial impression it's
hard to say
um this one's one where it's like oh I
think I need a lot more time in this but
right now
I very much want to play more than just
another 15 minutes like I am super into
this
and yeah just some of the systems I
don't understand I'd be interested to
see how forgiving
um you know boss fights are
obviously it's pretty easy right now
except for when I was up against the
that big 16 boy
um interested in in the equipment system
like there are things that I just have
oh this is definitely a boss fight
things that I just haven't seen yet
oh this is the one from the demo
oh I think
oh it's pretty slow all right bud I just
wanted to give it a try okay I'm just
out here trying to give me a second I
was just trying to try my lightning
through the tree
thanks dude yeah yeah I showed in it all
right hang on I'm trying to get out of
his way but he's very persistent
man's got range on him
I don't have any more and I do I missed
it again
[Applause]
I sure am I'm having a good time though
okay we can do it obviously mess that up
because I was like let me try this later
some enemies will have hardened limbs or
other parts of the body that will use to
perform critical blows
okay
Let's Roll
it's me making that noise
I thought that was him
all right let's do it
the fight is on
I shouldn't have tried to do it there at
all there we go
video
what does that mean
I was not ready for it
keep messing with that
[Music]
so he's got these two bars what is this
oh this is like his stamina
disregard
yeah that one sucks okay
Dodge
thanks I could really use the help
that one I'm having a little bit of
trouble with but obviously did well
there and it gives you like this nice
follow-up
when you um Dodge it correctly huh
it this game does unfortunately require
a lot of Rapid button presses which is
getting tough for me already
oh that was badly timed that was my
fault this is really fun though this is
really fun
um we'll look at it the next time
but yeah the it does does require a
pretty fast button mashing which anyone
who doesn't know is um the reason I got
so interested in accessibility is that I
have tendonitis in both of my wrists
from video games and
I don't imagine there is an
accessibility menu
it doesn't appear to be no which is a
shame
um
yeah it just means I can have a little
bit of pain in my like thumb stuff to
like lock up when I play anything that's
fast
yeah this one's really do suck if they
hit but oh I'm yeah I just need to slow
down hit him less
oh I got an achievement for that
successfully deflected 10 critical blows
nice
did I just miss that damn it I did
[Music]
foreign
this is really fun honestly I'm loving
it
diet nice
that should be it oh really really
really fun fight let's see how this goes
wait what do you mean what Jade
what Jade are you talking about
I still fighting the same way huh
[Applause]
oh [__] I need to get out of the way bad
really bad oh there you go
you got me
all right because I don't know how long
it's gonna take me I think we may leave
that to another time but
I really like this so far I think it's
very very fun
um I think there are some mechanics that
I'm like excited to learn more about I
think the animation in combat is awesome
outside of it kind of janky
um interested to see if it ends up being
buggy it just feels like it might be but
I have no way of knowing if that's the
case or not to be honest like really
very hard to tell
um very big thank you to koi tekma and
Xbox for providing me with a code I'm
definitely gonna be playing more of it
there's no way I don't play more of it